[Music]
access control capability in security
command center
allows organization administrators to
grant fine-grained access to the assets
and findings
surfaced in security command center this
feature is relevant for many use cases
including sensitive applications or
compliance regimes that require strict
access controls
as it lets you isolate cloud resources
and restrict employee access to only
those they need to do their jobs
access control at the folder and project
level is available to security command
center premium customers
in this video we'll walk through how to
grant granular access control to assets
and findings in your organization
and demonstrate the experience from the
end user's perspective
starting in the organization view of the
security command center
you can see this example organization
has thousands of assets
and similarly it has many findings
rather than providing organization-wide
permissions
administrators can use access control to
limit the view or edit permissions in
security command center to specific
folders and projects
we'll now show how to grant users access
to specific folders or projects in
security command center using the cloud
console
in the project selector drop-down choose
the project or folder to which you would
like to provide scoped access in this
case
we're selecting a project then head to
the iam landing page which you can find
with the left-hand navigation menu
search for the user's email address
and click to edit then add the security
center admin editor
viewer or one of the many additional
security center roles based on your
user's needs
then click save the permissions are now
applied and live for your user
now let's switch over to view the
console logged in as the user
as you can see when the user tries to
access security command center for the
organization itself
they will get a permission denied error
because they do not have permissions at
the organization level
using the project drop-down we'll select
the target project to which they were
granted security command center access
we'll now see security command center is
scoped to the specific project
including only the assets and findings
that are associated with the project
for example by selecting the assets tab
we can now see that the number of assets
has decreased from the organization view
we saw earlier
as now these are only the assets that
reside within this project
when looking at projects we can only see
the specific project and not
others within the organization we'll
click on a specific asset
such as this bucket to expand the asset
details
take note of the new canonical name
field which contains the asset's actual
parent
project id in its name now let's head to
the findings tab
again we can only see findings that are
associated with the assets contained in
this project
rather than the organization-wide
findings
note if we had shared access at the
folder level we would be able to see
assets and findings associated with all
projects within that folder
just as we saw earlier in the assets tab
we can see that the details for a
finding includes the new canonical name
field which identifies the parent
project associated with the finding
all functionality across dashboards is
scoped as per the
access controls defined for example in
the overview tab we continue to see the
charts and reports for findings within
the scope of this project
and we also see only the vulnerabilities
associated with this project
the settings page however does require
organization level permissions in order
to be viewed and edited
because security command center settings
always apply to the entire organization
congratulations you're now equipped to
use access control and security command
center to restrict users to manage
assets and findings within an assigned
[Applause]
[Music]
scope
you